i'm doug chang i'm the vice president
and executive career director for
lucasfilm
i'm amy beth christensen and i'm an art
director at lucasfilm and today we're
going to talk about every kind of
starfighter in the live-action star wars
films
and we do mean every starfighter
[Laughter]
always wanted to fly one of these things
there are many different classes of
starships
from capital ships like star destroyers
to space stations
like the death star that's no moon
it's a space station but typically we
define a star fighter as a small
spacecraft designed
specifically for combat spaceship
designs in star wars is really really
tricky and that's because we have to
give these spaceships personality
they have to have a distinct look they
have to have a distinct iconic shape and
that's where i think george was
brilliant in terms of creating
iconic shapes for star wars tie fighters
they're one of the most iconic designs
in the star wars universe and what i
like about it is the simplicity of it
it's just the ball with wings the
original design for the tie fighter was
presented by george to ralph mcquarrie
in 1974. i think all of the ships in
star wars
you can kind of do that shorthand like
almost a stick figure version of it and
this tie fighter is great because it's
the h with the ball on it yeah so as
long as it's coming towards you you
recognize it as a tie fighter
i remember when i first saw it when i
was 15 part the visual was so strong but
i loved the sound of it it was just
an amazing unexpected sound
i see them the first time we see darth
vader's tie advanced is in the trench
run
at the end of the new hope one of the
fun facts about it in terms of design is
that george wanted to look very
distinguished they're very different in
terms of
giving it a very distinct silhouette the
wings are folded in to kind of
evoke power and menace
the t-65 x-wing is a really fascinating
design i love the fact that it evokes
war ii
aircraft design in terms of the form
language
and i also like the idea that it has a
long snout george was a huge race car
fan and he loved the idea that the
dragsters had a very long nose and so in
some of the early prototypes from colin
cantwell
you can see the same painted nose great
thing about the x-wing is
seeing star wars for the first time it
was kind of the first time you saw a
ship transform
when you get the s foils being locked in
attack position that's when it makes its
x
silhouette shape and it was really fun
to see one of the reasons why the x-wing
is so iconic is that
joe johnson when he drew it and designed
it i mean he made it very graphic
it was very easy to understand it was
very easy to draw very quickly
and there's a timeless quality to it
that's very hard to do
the y-wing the first time we see a
y-wing is when they arrived on yavin
base
one of the fun things about the y-wing
was that george wanted it to look like a
race car without
all of its paneling and so you can see
that the cockpit has the sleekness of a
race car but then the engines in the
body have all the panels removed the
design actually evolved quite a bit
because
of the blue screen technology the very
thin struts were very hard to photograph
and so colin kant will actually beat
them up and gave it a more stronger
war to robustness we were able to design
the fully covered y-wing where we got to
see it in its complete form before you
see it in a new hope
the design for the tie bomber is really
unique because this is the first time we
saw two pods next to each other with
kind of this thai advanced wing set up
it still felt more menacing and then you
got a hint at what it does when they
were trying to bomb the falcon
and the asteroid field
the a-wing the first time we see the
a-wing is the return of the jedi and
it's one of my favorite designs because
it's so fast and it's very sleek in many
ways
it's the bare essence of speed because
you just have a cockpit with engines and
a wing and i love the triangular look of
it because it just looks fast
the a-wing for me is really interesting
because this one the first time we saw a
really rounded shape for the fighters at
least
and i thought that that made it really
unique looking luck s files and attack
positions
[Music]
viewing from return of the jedi one of
the fun things about the b-wing design
is that it's a transforming design
the fact that it's almost a flying wing
but then it goes vertical
and i love the idea that the cockpit
actually rotates it's the first time
we've seen that
and the whole thinking about that is
that when it's flying it's actually a
very interesting configuration than when
it's landed
[Music]
coming in the thai interceptor what's
great about this design is the next
evolution of the thai fighter the high
interceptor is one of my favorite ship
designs
and one of the interesting things is
that we took the wings and stretched it
so that it made it look more forward
propelling and then
by doing that though we had to actually
give it a slot so the pilot could
actually look left and right
[Music]
the naboo n1 starfighter one of the
challenges of designing that was that we
actually had to figure out a design
history for star wars
and george wanted to mirror that design
history with our real world design
and so for instance the original trilogy
designs of the x-wing and the y-wing
were more in the 1970s the more
manufactured look the more angular look
and so episodes one two and three
actually went back to the 1920s a more
romantic time more handcrafted
artisan look for the design of the
spaceships an astromech droid does fit
in there or
on this one it does okay that's one of
the fun things about designing for star
wars is that we can take a lot of
liberties
and part of the sleekness of the n1 is
that you really can't get an astromech
behind the cockpit and so if you notice
it it's just
r2's dome his legs are somewhere inside
the body
the other important thing about the
naboo starfighter is that doug designed
it
the trade federation vulture droid and
the first time we see this is episode
one phantom menace the thing that's
really cool about this is the first time
we see
a starfighter in star wars that is a
droid and at first originally it wasn't
supposed to be a droid
i remember george actually wanted to
start to connect the idea
of the designs from episode one to
episode four and so this was going to be
a precursor to the tie fighters and
that's why you see the distinct wing
configuration in the central ball body
the geos no cn starfighter we first see
that in attack of the clones and what's
interesting about this design is that
george is a
huge race boat fan and so he wanted to
mirror and design
a vehicle that looked kind of like the
f1 speed boats and that's where you get
the twin pontoons and now what i did was
turn them vertically
the great part about the design of the
geonosian starfighter is that you really
see that it's designed by the geonosians
they're bug-like creatures so they have
their own distinct look to their
vehicles
one of the fun things is that when i was
designing it i wanted to make sure that
the spaceship actually looked almost
like part of the geonosians and so
that's why the cockpit is really small
it's almost like a helmet
the jedi starfighter at this time george
wanted to blend and blur the line so you
can see here you know even though these
are jedi ships
we actually kept them very triangular to
sort of evoke a little bit of the
transition towards the empire star
destroyers
and one of the fun things was that i
remember george saying let's just take a
star destroyer and turn into a fighter
ship that was such a bold statement at
first i didn't think it would work until
i actually saw it on paper and it
actually works beautifully this little
nerdy
part where um it doesn't have hyperspace
capabilities so it needs a hyperspace
ring to
go into hyperspace we're on your tail
general kenobi the arc 170 starfighter
and the first time we see this is in
revenge of the sith
my favorite part about this design are
the multiple wings of the different
designs really cool
it's actually a precursor to the x-wing
so the multiple wings sort of
start to hint at the x-wing s-foil
folding out but then the interesting
thing is that you'll notice that there
are multiple cockpits
and pilots and gunners and that's to
call back to the original inspiration
for this which is the douglas dauntless
fighter bomber
this is the droid tri fighter and the
first time we see this is a revenge of
the sith
one of the interesting things about this
is it's the next evolution of droid
starfighter ships
and it's very aggressive and it's
distinctly designed to look mean and
menacing
[Music]
general grievous is a starfighter what's
interesting about this is that this is
the most automotive of all the star
fighters and you'll notice that the
cockpit is set way back and you have
this long hood
sort of connoting power and engine and
the engines are oversized
and so all about this design is about
power and speed
and general grievous is the general of
the separatist army
he was an alien who like darth vader he
had to replace a lot of his parts so
he's mostly droid when we see him
and his two arms split into four arms
and he's got four lightsabers a lot of
things about the prequels kind of hint
at what's coming
general grievous is kind of a precursor
to vader in those respects
jedi interceptor the first time we see
this ship is the revenge of the sith
one of the interesting things is that in
the design language we're actually
starting to sort of tie in story
elements that
you know the the good guys become the
bad guys and you'll notice in the jedi
interceptor that we're really starting
to tie
and bridge the jedi starfighter with the
thai fighters
you'll notice that the wings when they
unfold have sort of early distinct
silhouettes of the tie fighter and then
the cockpit is actually starting to
become a ball
and one of the other interesting facts
is that the r2 unit can't fit in it the
body is actually too
thin so the r2 unit has to be a really
short one
we got him aren't you
the p-38 fighter the original
inspiration was the p-38 lightning and
that's where you see the twin tails on
there
and as the design evolved slowly we
start to modify so that we took the
round wings off and then we actually
removed the connecting tailpiece
but you can see connecting elements like
the engine scoops are actually scoops on
the p-38 lightning this is the techno
union fighter the first time we see this
is a revenge of the sith it has a very
fresh garden-esque feel to it and george
was very inspired by flash gordon i
think star wars itself is sort of
inspired by flash gordon and george's
love of it
and that can be seen in ships like the
techno union fighter
v-wing from revenge of the sith so you
can kind of get a hint at what's going
to come in a new hope but i think
this probably is the most extreme if you
look at it head-on has more of that tie
fighter
silhouette where you kind of see the h
with the ball in the middle
the first order tie fighter and keeping
to our design philosophy
were 789 were more contemporary times we
wanted to update the tie fighter and
part of the thinking was that maybe the
tie fighter for the first order
they made it more robust using new
materials to make it faster and leaner
and more
strong and so part of the idea was that
we actually took the classic design of
the tie fighter
and just beefed it up changed the
material changed the configuration of
the colors
this thing really moves the first order
of special force is tie fighter
we distinguish them by giving them red
but then we also gave them external
magazines for the weaponry
the other thing that distinguishes the
special forces tie fighter is actually
has two seats back to back in the
cockpit
you've got the gunner in the back you've
got the pilot in the front so that's
when poe and finn are actually piloting
when they escape
the p70 resistance x-wing the
inspiration for this was actually ralph
mccoy's original
painting of the x-wing where he actually
had the twin
turbine of the engine split down the
middle for the split wing
and it was a very sleek design it really
looked like an f1 car mixed with a
spaceship the t70 is a little bit
obsolete
in the star wars universe even at the
time of the force awakens the resistance
still doesn't get all the new stuff
right yeah exactly part of the charm of
the t70 design is that it evokes the
original trilogy design
that it's scrapping the resistance at
this time didn't have a whole lot of
resources so they have leftovers
the thai striker from rogue one one of
the most interesting things about the
thai striker is that we want to come up
with a new idea for
a thai fighter and we thought how would
it actually operate in the atmosphere
and so we turn the wings up so there are
almost like
wings up on top and then the ball is
suspended below and so it has a slight
hang glider configuration and it really
sort of helps to communicate the idea
that this tie fighter this unique tie
fighter
operates in the atmosphere
[Music]
the resistance a-wing the great part
about this design is it really evokes
the original a-wing design but i like
the
the engines are even more beefed up than
the original and the great thing is that
it is sort of the next evolution it's
the next model
and in this one in particular you can
see the power and the speed in terms of
the form language
resistance bomber and the first time we
see this is at the very beginning
of the last jedi and one of the
interesting things about is that we want
to evoke
sort of old technology so this is
obviously an old bomber
and the vertical spine is actually
almost like an ammunition cartridge of a
gun
the great thing about the bomb magazine
pointing downwards is it kind of gives
you that hint that the
artificial gravity well is going to be
used so that way the bombs can actually
fall in space
follow my lead the thai silencer
basically the concept for that is we
want to give kylo
something really unique and we just
basically took the thai interceptor and
just stretched it even more to make it
even more aggressive
it also reminds me of kylo's mask
because you see the silver framework
around the cockpit and that kind of
reminds me of the silver around his mask
when we design spaceships they do tie
into the personality of the character
that's going to be piloting it
and for kylo ship it was really trying
to invoke the menace that we see in
kylo's mask and so how do we translate
that into a spaceship form
and part of that was just the form
language just making it more aggressive
making it more pointed so it looks like
it's the flying dagger
this is the thai brute and the first
time we see it is in solo during the
castle run
this is really interesting to me because
this is the first really asymmetrical
tie design
the bomber if you drew it shorthand was
still you know everything else has been
yeah it was an interesting play to try
to put a separate ball turret
for the gun and it's sort of it's
interesting in the sense that it still
feels very tie fighter-ish but yet it
looks like it's a more brutish version
of it
the resistance b-wing we first see that
in the rise of skywalker and it's
basically an updated model from the
b-wing that we saw in return of the jedi
the updates are primarily just
you know thinning down the shapes make
it a little bit sleeker and then adding
new coloration
the resistance y wing first introduced
in rise of skywalker and just like the
resistance x-wing
this one also evokes a little bit more
of that original ralph mcquarrie
painting
hi dagger the first time we see it is in
rise of skywalker and it's basically the
next evolution of the tie fighter
part of the idea was that we wanted to
give it a very angular aggressive look
and so we took the triangular shapes of
the star destroyers and put them into
the wings
and the red markings on the tie dagger
denote that they're sith
the thai whisper the first time we see
it is in the rise of skywalker kylo ren
has a modifier version with longer wings
the design for this
really feels like the original tie but
you can see it's got the extra armor
around the cockpit
and it's red so it's evil
we have two bonus ships that are
technically not starfighters but they're
so cool there's no way we're not
including them
the first one is the ghost from star
wars rebels but you can see it fight in
rogue one
and in rise of skywalker that ship was
originally designed for rebels it's
piloted by hara syndulla and the rest of
the ghost crew and then for the design
of that originally
felony was really drawn to the diamond
shape so from the top down you can see
it's got that distinct perfect diamond
silhouette
but you really wanted it to feel like
the falcon and it was also inspired by
b17 bombers from world war
ii that's where you get the rounded
cockpit from the front
the millennium falcon is probably the
most iconic design for star wars and one
of my favorite
i mean it's so timeless i remember when
i first saw it it was just like wow
that's a ship that i want to be on
the original design actually was the
blockade runner and it had the very
distinct
falcon cockpit on there but then george
wanted to create something that was a
little bit more unique and he decided
that you know let's keep the cockpit but
let's turn it into something more iconic
and so he suggested that perhaps we
should make it round
more like a saucer and so joe johnston
when he designed it again
he actually gave it some front mandibles
to give it some direction
and by combining that with an offset
cockpit it gave it a really distinct
personality that was unlike anything
that we had seen at that time
i like the falcon a lot because it feels
very fast it's got a subtle curve to the
top and the bottom
it kind of looks like kind of saucer
feel but also makes it feel very fast i
love the engines
on the falcon i love it there's a strip
of blue light in the back part of the
charm of the millennium falcon is that
it is a character it is a star wars
character and so i want to imbue it with
a lot of
personality and like a character it
evolves there's a character arc to it
and so one of the first tasks that we
had was for solo we want to see an
earlier version of the millennium falcon
sort of the cleaner version prior to han
solo coming in and sort of hot rodding
it
and so in solo you see all the panels
are intact and there's actually the
escape pod that actually fits between
the front mandibles
and as you progress into the original
trilogy it becomes more beaten up
you came nothing you're braver than i
thought it becomes more robust you can
see
hans touch in terms of how he beat up
the engine made it more robust
made it more practical in some ways and
then moving forward to
episode 789 you can start to see how the
falcon has been repaired after all its
various adventures you know where it
knocks off its
radar dish and return the jedi and how
there's a new radar dish and so
all those little evolutionary things
help to inform the evolution of the
character of the falcon and it's
interesting because the falcon is so
iconic that even with all these slight
variations you know that it's the falcon
and one of the beautiful things about
what we're doing now
for rise of skywalker is that we're
consolidating all those designs to
create the iconic
millennium pocket
what a piece of junk she'll make 0.5
past light speed
she may not look like much but she's got
it where it counts kid that was every
starfighter in the live-action star wars
films and we can't wait to show you
what we have coming up next
[Music]
you